people's identity might be changing
because Elon Musk is going to turn us
into cyborgs musk has just announced the
first implantation into a human being of
a neural link chip neural link is the
technology that musk has been working on
for a long time and made a big leap
forward in it about 3 four years ago
said okay we've got the chip we're doing
tests still a lot of people were
skeptical that would ever go into a
human well now we've got a chip in a
human the chip is the size of a quarter
the ship sends out brain signal data to
an app the app decodes the data and
translates it into actions meaning you
can control devices with your
thoughts you people who are say
extremely paralyzed you know not just
they have trouble moving around like
they're just totally paralyzed they
might be able to communicate they might
be able to communicate faster than you
can
communicate this kind of this kind of
Technology could help the paralyze
communicate it could help the blind to
see it could help the deaf to hear and
it could meld human beings with robots
and open us up to hacking hacking our
own identities or being hacked by you
know the Chinese Communist party or
something back in 2021 Elon Musk said
that once neuralink develops you could
probably
save save your brain like a video game
like you know D right now it's you know
late January of 2024
save okay and then you know you keep
living you know a month or so and then
God forbid something happens to you okay
well you already saved the file so
you're going to lose your memories from
February 2024 but you got the file and
you can just reanimate yourself and
you'll basically be you you'll lose a
few memories but you'll be yourself
whatever you means that's what he
promised and he he does seem to be
achieving a lot of his transhumanist
goals so is this good or
bad some people saying this is awful we
you know kill it shoot it shoot the
technology we don't want this it's going
to bring on the end of the world and
Destroy Humanity some saying well what's
what's the matter with you you're a lite
this is a way to help people who are
severely disabled to be able to live
better lives which is it well that's the
distinction I think you've hit on it
that is the distinction if this
technology is used to re restore the
functioning that is proper to human
beings if it is used in a way that is
medicinal and therapeutic then it could
be a good
thing if however the technology is used
to
augment Humanity to transform Humanity
not not to fix a problem but to create a
new type of human then I think that's
probably very very bad you can think of
it as the difference between adoption
and
surrogacy adoption is a beautiful
wonderful thing because it uh extends
through race and charity
um the ability to fix a problem the
problem being a child born out of
wedlock a child uh who potentially could
have been killed through abortion a
child who is without parents then the
child gets parents and that fixes a
problem it's a beautiful charitable
graceful Act surrogacy is when you breed
babies and treat human beings as
Commodities and sell them on the open
market very very bad it's like the
difference between a a dog shelter and a
breeder except there's nothing immoral
about breeding puppies there there is
something immoral about breeding humans
humans are different from puppies humans
are morally significant
creatures
and if you augment Humanity through this
new technology such that it's
unrecognized able well you you may have
just abolished Humanity you might you
might be committing an immoral action on
that immoral creature that's it and the
problem right now is the way Elon Musk
talks about it it's a little bit of both
which is it well the answer is going to
be that we need a lot of regulation on
this industry regulation would be good
self-regulation from the companies
developing this I guess it's mostly Elon
and government regulation I know words
you're not supposed to say if you're a
right- Winger but when we're talking
about you know abolishing man uh
when you when you're talking about
transcending Homo sapiens and turning
Homo sapiens into
homodeus God man as uh Yuval Harari a
darling intellectual public intellectual
on the left suggests uh then I think you
need a little regulation on this issue
of the US getting more or less involved
in the war in the Middle
East there is oddly enough a consensus
now you've got most of the GOP base
saying no no thank you you've got some
of the prominent GOP players saying No
thank
you you've got a lot of the leftwing
base probably most of it saying No thank
you you even have a host on
MSNBC maybe not openly but when she gets
caught on a hot mic on her own show Joy
Reed on MSNBC you hear what she really
thinks about Joe Biden's response to the
Middle East over the weekend President
Biden said he's ready to take action if
Congress is serious about solving the
Border
issue if that bill were the law today
I'd shut down the border right now and
fix it quickly and Congress needs to get
it done starting another
War still trying to kill the deal
starting another effing War what oh uh
oh this look this happens sometimes when
you're on air you cut to a clip and then
you think your mic is cut so I will you
let's say I'm I say all right let's I
could have done it during this clip you
cut to the clip and then I don't know I
need to blow my nose or I need to go
yell at Professor Jacob or producer Mr
Ben Davies or I whatever I'm going to do
right you do it and then you hope you're
all but sometimes they leave the
microphone on and beautifully here she's
expressing her real feelings about Joe
Biden right now this is a Democrat hack
Joy Reed is as dam hack as it gets she's
going here we go Joe Biden again
starting another effing War this guy
driving me crazy I want to pull my hair
out I hate this guy everyone everyone is
sick of Joe Biden
everybody your uncle your
co-workers the Republicans The
Independents even the big Libs on MSNBC
the guy is in trouble he's begging
Taylor Swift to campaign with him bad
shape that's very good news for Donald
Trump especially because Donald
Trump Donald Trump remade the GOP in a
lot of different ways and he didn't you
know make a hard break from history a
total Destruction of the GOP as all the
squishes and the never trumpers want to
say actually what Donald Trump did in as
much as he changed the GOP was to
restore it to what it had always been go
the GOP for most of its history was
skeptical of foreign intervention was
was cautious in the use of military
force abroad that changed a little bit
with the neocons toward the end of the
20 Century in the early early 21st but
most of the time was pretty restrained
up to including Ronald Reagan saying no
thanks we don't need to be in
Lebanon on tariffs the GOP was founded
on tariffs it was a protectionist party
for most of its history even when the
free Traders took over at the end of the
20th century you still had massive steel
tariffs coming up under Ronald Reagan
you still had George George W bush
raising tarff so and then obviously
Trump makes it a big deal on on
immigration GOP had always been
restriction until the squishes got
control at the end and they said oh we
need unlimited migration it's just got
to be legal and we can give amnesty to
all these illegals and what so Trump
restored it the war part is really big
though the GOP the conservatives were
more restrained in their foreign policy
and that's the popular position right
now that they told me if I voted for
Trump in 2020 we would get another war
in the Middle East and they were exactly
right I voted for Trump in 2020 we got
another war in the Middle
East this is a this is a huge winning
issue for Trump right now sorry for the
Republicans and the presumptive
Republican nominee who's obviously
Donald Trump major major losing issue
for Joe Biden don't believe me take it
from the horse's mouth that horse being
Joy Reid on MSNBC that was a great clip
huh now hold up ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael nlls YouTube channel see
you next time